to explain the difference between child
protection and child safeguarding and
it's actually very complicated often
because in so many languages we don't
have a word for safeguarding but what we
kind of do on a European level what the
Council of Europe does the European
Union and the UN UNICEF we've all kind
of established a safeguarding as kind of
an internal structure whilst protection
is more external so when we talk about
protection we talk about the systems the
um the structures around kind of
anything that has to do with with a
country or with the institutions in the
country and so on how we protect the
children from harm but when we talk
about safeguarding we look inside
ourselves and we look inside our
organization and we say how are we
making sure that in anything that we do
within our organization we're keeping
children safe so when we talk about why
safeguarding is so important it is
mainly because
so many people do wrong by not knowing
better so a lot of safeguarding breaches
that happen simply happened because
people haven't been taught and they
haven't been taught to think in a
certain direction and think about the
consequences of their actions so small
things that you might consider to be
minimal might actually be a bigger in in
the big context and these are very often
things that might seem very
straightforward but aren't and just
getting that kind of notion into
people's head about how we Safeguard
children and how we make sure that
interaction and we are always putting
the benefit of the child first this also
escalates within individuals so as soon
as you start this process and start this
this thought people then can kind of
follow it themselves as well